some Republicans are now joining
Democrats on Capitol Hill in a push to
examine general Flynn's conduct House
and Senate committees are already
investigating Russian influence on the
election and now there is growing debate
over whether Congress should conduct a
separate investigation to the
circumstances surrounding Flint's
dismissal Nancy Cordes is on capitol
hill with a spreading fallout nancy good
morning good morning both sides agree
that Flynn was right to resign and that
the public deserves to know more but
Democrats argue the GOP which controls
Congress is holding back and needs to
aggressively investigate any and all
ties between this White House and Russia
general Flynn's resignation is not the
end of the story it is merely the
beginning Democrats renewed their calls
Tuesday for a Watergate style committee
to investigate the administration's ties
with Russia our committee held three or
four hearings emergency hearings on
Hillary Clinton in a matter of a week or
two and if there was any emergency at
this moment in the history of this
country this is the moment in the Senate
the Republican chairs of the
intelligence Foreign Relations and Armed
Services committee's all said the Flynn
resignation should be examined one of
them Senator John McCain said this
administration's foreign policy requires
more oversight environment is one of
dysfunction
illustration as far as national security
we're still gathering information the
House and Senate intelligence committees
are already examining Russia's meddling
in US elections for now it looks like
any probe of Flynn's contacts with
Russia will be folded into those
investigations I think it's likely that
general Flynn will be at some point
asked to come and talk to the committee
about both post-election activities and
any other activities that he would be
aware of some Republicans argued the
real problem isn't Flynn it's the leaks
about his phone calls we're concerned
any time intelligence has publicly
talked about a very candid Rand Paul of
Kentucky said in a radio interview that
Republicans in Congress shouldn't waste
too much time investigating Republicans
in the White House because it gets in
the way of their shared agenda Nora
which includes repealing Obamacare